I had a cat his name probably would be
fluffy CC des Princes meow I think it's
a good name David thing out of the
ordinary I am an executive director at
Canyon trails assisted living my
responsibility is making sure that our
residents are well taken care of they're
engaged and living a vibrant life I can
guarantee they'll talk about this for
the next three weeks
your surprise will be here shortly
what's your name they're dressed up
they're ready to go they're energetic I
think for the first time in a long time
they're all at breakfast on time I'm
excited there's a good vibe in the
building I think they'll be surprised
this should be a nice experience for the
residents
there are lots of therapy dogs and
therapy horses not many people associate
Getty therapy with a cat this is Aragon
I just let him do his magic this is my
kitty cat named mister a lot of people
can't believe how gentle and how relaxed
he starts purring right away he's so
chillax with my cat monkey I could
really identify how calm he was and how
much he enjoyed personal interaction I
don't know if monkey knows he's a
therapy cat I know that he knows he's
very popular
I think Aragon thinks he's a big star
yes I think he knows he's a therapy cat
[Music]
Oh kid again you're a cutie hi Kevin
are so cute you are adorable yes you are
when you go in to do a visit you don't
know what you're gonna get course he's
calm and of course he's very friendly he
also has to be very predictable oh boy
oh boy oh boy
not many cats can become a therapy cat
they have to have a certain temperament
they have to be able to handle other
animals in the room interact with lots
of ruckus and noise oh look how
comfortable he is oh you're gonna eat Oh
were you hungry look at all that food
you've got Aragon is very experienced
with this kind of work and I think he
enjoyed it thoroughly it's important to
read the the people in the room and the
animal and be heightened to how the
interactions are going they surprised
was a great surprise and it gives us a
place to escape a little bit I saw all
the cat I joined it I enjoyed it it's
gonna talk to them and they don't give
me a bad answers cats they're just like
people they have to be given love and
care once they feel it and see it then
they learn to trust you you can't really
hold a cat the cat holds you
[Music]